one point i got arrested like
food outside of here
but i began all good promise but that
was
probably the least
traumatizing
moment in this whole thing for as far as
ukraine is concerned maxim schmierkovsky
says he was arrested and is preparing to
get out of ukraine i'm going to try to
make my way out
i'm going to try to
start getting towards the border the
ballroom pro who has been in the country
for the last few months filming world of
dance shared an update with his fans on
monday revealing he was arrested in
keeve at one point i got arrested like
food outside of here the 42 year old
dancing with the stars alum doesn't go
into detail about his arrest but does
note that it was a wake-up call for me
it was just a reality check you know no
matter
no matter what it is and how it is it
was a crazy reality check anyway there's
a lot to unpack and like i said i'm not
in a mental state right now to do so i'm
just trying to stay stay focused before
signing off he explains that he's trying
to make his way out of ukraine and will
do his best to keep his followers
updated along the way i'm gonna try to
make my way out
i'm gonna try to
start go getting towards the border
um i have options my options are better
than
than most people's unfortunately but i
um just a little nervous to be honest
with you but you know i think it's gonna
be all right
well i know it's gonna be okay so
i'm gonna just keep you posted through
this process as i can
i just want a favor from everybody
just don't panic
if i kind of disappear for a minute not
long after that max posted this to his
insta story writing that he's really not
good right this moment quote innocent
people are being killed continue to
scream about this genocide at the top of
your lungs
[Music]
max's latest update well the pro dancer
revealed on monday that he made it onto
a train headed for warsaw poland of
course max has been speaking out on
social media for the past week after
russia first invaded his home country
honestly i'm getting really emotional
it's been a little difficult
you know me you know me i stay strong
and i don't show it
but
but
i want to go back home meanwhile maxim's
brother val went on his insta story
monday and called out their russian
friends and fellow ballroom dancers
writing in part quote to all the russian
speaking friends that are quietly
continuing to stay in your lane ignoring
what's happening
you are spineless little
i will remind you of that next time we
line up on that dance floor
gravitate to the things that affect us
directly and i understand that and you
know i'm also
you know
i'm an american
but
there's certain things that
that are just instinctively inside of
you right and and you just you just
understand what's right even though yes
there are two sides to every story but
but certain things are just
black and white
[Music]